meine damen und herren liebe freunde ich
begrüße sie alle ganz herzlich zu
unserem 19 bundesparteitag und ich bitte
um verzeihung dass es halt wieder etwas
später geworden ist
mir ist die ehre zuteil geworden vom
bundesvorstand diesen parteitag zu
eröffnen mit einer rede
liebe freunde ein alter chinesischer
flug lautet musst du in aufregenden
zeiten leben
aufregend ist unsere zeit gewiss und wir
müssen die herausforderung annehmen die
diese zeit und stellt damit unsere enkel
nicht eines tages uns verfluchen weil
wir die herausforderung nicht angenommen
haben
[Applaus]
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht aber
ich fühle mich derzeit immer wieder an
die letzten monate der ddr erinnert ich
will die s ich will die sed-diktatur
keineswegs bagatellisieren
doch vergleiche drängen sich einfach auf
und vergleichen heißt ja nicht
gleichsetzen wieder vorkommt ein land
weil seine führung vor bord einer
zerstörerischen ideologie folgt wie
damals besteht das regime aus einer
kleinen gruppe von parteifunktionären
eine art politbüro und wieder steht ein
breites gesellschaftliches bündnis aus
block parteifunktionären journalisten
tv-moderatoren kirchenfunktionäre
künstlern lehrern professoren
kabarettisten und anderen engagierten
hinter der staatsführung und bekämpft
die opposition wie damals liebe freunde
gehen heute unbotmäßige bürger auf die
straße um ihre rechte einzufordern
wieder werden diese bürgerrechtler von
schlägern verfolgt von den medien
diffamiert und in ihren betrieben
denunziert wieder ist sachsen das herz
des widerstandes
[Applaus]
ja ich weiß ich könnte alle anderen
länder auch nennen aber von sachsen ist
damals vieles ausgegangen und wieder
sind es die freiheitsliebenden polen und
ungarn die sich als erste gegen die
befehle aus dem brüssler kreml auflehnen
[Applaus]
die einzige oppositionspartei afd ist
sozusagen das aktuelle neue forum wie
damals gilt heute jeder der sich gegen
die politik des regimes ausspricht als
faschist was ist ewig gestriger und was
dergleichen namen mehr sind die wut mit
welcher das ist milieu auf den
widerstand reagiert erinnert ebenfalls
an 1989
viele freunde die schweizer zeitungen
sind das neue westfernsehen karl-eduard
heißt heute mal
[Applaus]
karl-eduard heißt heute mal marietta mal
klaus der große bruder der sich
abgewendet hat sendet seine klassen
botschaften inzwischen via twitter über
den atlantik während der
imperialistische hauptfeind nicht mehr
in übersee sondern wieder im osten steht
deutschland ist derzeit mit den russen
wegen putin verfeindet mit den
amerikanern wegen trump mit den briten
wegen des drecks it die beziehung zu den
polen ungarn italien und sogar
österreich sind miserabel
meine damen und herren liebe freunde der
letzte deutsche regierungschef der eine
solche konstellation gegen sich
aufgebracht hat
[Applaus]
ich habe aber nicht verglichen liebe
freunde seit einem dreivierteljahr sitz
unserer parteien bundestag wie sie unter
anderem am permanent hochroten kopf von
herrn hofreiter bemerken können
[Applaus]
manchmal habe ich sorge um seine
gesundheit wenn wir reden für unsere
politischen mitbewerber von denen schon
etwas älteren parteien ist es ist das
bis heute ein job nicht nur weil der
applaus von 92 ende fahren für aussagen
die in diesem haus jahre lang tabu waren
auf einmal nach pluralismus klingt ihre
angst vor dem demos haben die
derzeitigen funktionseliten bekanntlich
im begriff populismus versteckt der
frische populistische gegenwind ist
ungewohnt für die neuen blockparteien
der große bayerische kabarettist gerhard
polt hat diese mentalität an adressen
mit den satz beschrieben die braucht
opposition weil die bin said amakran
mayr ist es nicht so gut wie das von
meinem lieben kollegen potschka liebe
freunde viele von ihnen kennen das aus
den landtag
man kommt in ein fremdes aus
funktionieren und bürokraten bestehendes
system in dem alles neu kompliziert und
unverständlich ist vieles läuft
informell und auf schleichwegen und man
wird von denen die sich schon länger
dort eingerichtet haben geschnitten oder
sogar gehasst aber in jedem fall
behindert die medien die seit ungefähr
fünf jahren oppositionskritik stadt
regierungskritik als ihre hauptaufgabe
betrachten
[Applaus]
schlachten natürlich jedes missgeschick
genüsslich aus und solche gibt es
natürlich mit der afg sind auf einmal
sozusagen die feinde im lager die
leighton sogar ausschüsse und stellen
fragen zum beispiel fragen sie im
europaausschuss warum alle vorlagen aus
brüssel immer nur diskussionslos
abgelegt und durchgewinkt werden diese
schlimmen afd abgeordneten stellen die
gesamte demokratie simulation in frage
die im höchsten deutschen parlament
routiniert ab gestaltung
[Applaus]
und liebe freunde das werden wir
weiterhin tun bis dieses parlament
endlich wieder die sorgen des volkes
behandelt und des volkes willen wirklich
abbildet
[Applaus]
liebe freunde unsere politischen
mitbewerber regen sich immer ganz
fürchterlich über unsere parlamentsreden
auf mit der afg ist endlich bewegung in
diesen langweiligen laden gekommen
die gute alte einhelligkeit ist dahin
das sind die gar nicht mehr gewöhnt
gewesen im gegensatz zu den meisten
stores schon länger herum sitzen denn
die zeit ihres lebens vom steuerzahler
aus gehalten wurden
[Applaus]
haben die asd abgeordneten alle einen
beruf und kommen aus dem wirklichen
leben mit uns ist das wirkliche leben in
dieses selbstzufriedene
parallelgesellschaft eingezogen und da
werden wir auch bleiben
[Applaus]
aber aus deren sich sind wir natürlich
eine laienspielgruppe mit dir haben mit
ihrer selbstüberschätzung geglaubt es
würden ein paar stammende blödmänner ans
rednerpult treten die man mit links
wegbügeln kann
und ausgerechnet diese angebliche
laienspieltruppe führt ihnen vor wie
miserabel und argument befreit und
alternativlos ihrer eigenen auftritte
sind
[Applaus]
die wütenden reaktionen auf unsere reden
sind oft nur routine und pflichtprogramm
aber als wir uns gegen diätenerhöhungen
ausgesprochen haben oder die
abgeordneten aufforderung zu gunsten der
ausschussarbeit auf eine urlaubswoche zu
verzichten sind wir auf wirklichen hass
gestoßen liebe freunde
so dürfen wir niemals werden
wie die bundeskanzlerin ohne erkennbare
mühe ihre meinung ins glatte gegenteil
verkehren kann erst die laufzeiten der
atomkraftwerke verlängern dann
atomkraftwerke abschalten
multikulti und integration für
gescheitert erklären dann die grenzen
öffnen
so sind auch viele abgeordnete der
altparteien in ihrer meinungsbildung
sehr elastisch wie wir es gerade bei der
csu erleben aber darauf kann ich noch
langsam und unmerklich übernehmen die
selben leute die uns an giften und
verleumden unsere positionen der
französischen moralisten warum sagte
einmal hat man 24 stunden früher als die
übrigen menschenrecht so gilt man 24
stunden lang für nearest ja es ist nur
länger als 24 stunden inzwischen
[Applaus]
jahrelang ohne opposition zu herrschen
macht dumm
der spd-politiker thomas oppermann hat
die wahl von frank-walter steinmeier zum
bundespräsidenten
sie wissen wie die wahl zustande kamen
ein fest der demokratie genannt
liebe freunde es war zu allen zeiten der
dreiste übermut dieses milieu der dessen
ende eingeleitet hat und dieses ende
wird ein wirkliches fest der demokratie
sein
liebe freunde ich habe den namen erwähnt
und ich weiß dass herr steinmeier unser
bundespräsident ist und ich achte das
höchste amt im staate aber auch der
bundespräsident kann sich nicht schämen
für einen teil des volkes und für dessen
repräsentanten
[Applaus]
er kann mit uns diskutieren er kann
anderer meinung sein
er kann auch politisch die afg angreifen
da habe ich nichts dagegen wir können
uns wehren
aber es geht nicht uns moralisch
auszugrenzen und das tut man wenn man
sich angeblich schämt
[Applaus]
womit ihr wieder im jahre 1989 werden in
diesem bild viele frau merkel die rolle
des genossen honecker zu auch rhetorisch
spielt die kanzlerin honeckers liga
[Applaus]
seit nunmehr drei jahren ist merkel muss
weg die parole der opposition
ich hoffe dass er eines tages erfahren
werden ob diese unselige person eine
agenda verfolgt hat oder tatsächlich
bloß um jeden preis und ohne jedes
prinzip oben bleiben wollte
jedenfalls liebe freunde ist der kipp
punkt überschritten
merkel hält egal wie lange sie noch mit
den armen rudert
[Applaus]
sie hat ihre partei gespalten sie hat
unser land gespalten
und sie hat deutschland in europa
isoliert wie erich honecker auf und sie
hat im gesamten ostblock ehemaligen
keinen einzigen verbündeten mehr wie es
auch anleger am ende ging mit frau kramp
karrenbauer hat sie ihren egon krenz
schon in stellung gebracht
[Applaus]
liebe freunde kramp-karrenbauer dieser
sperrige name lässt sich fabelhaft
einkürzen auf merkel 2 auch ein hans
modrow wäre bereit
der heißt heute wolfgang schäuble fühlte
sich 1 bevor märkten ihn weg bis als der
legitime erbe helmut kohls und er wird
diesen traum nie ganz ausgeträumt haben
warten wir es ab liebe freunde sie haben
längst bemerkt worauf ich hinaus will
merkel muss weg das ist ein griffiger
slogan doch hier doch hier muss ein
ganzer apparat ein ganzes system eine
ganze mentalität weckt nicht nur die
führende genossen
[Applaus]
die von merkel entkernte aller fähigen
köpfe beraubte und gefügig gemacht union
muss weg aus der regierung
[Applaus]
eine partei die in westen ostblock
manier ihre vorsitzenden für eine
kaskade von plattitüden elf minuten
standing ovations spendet muss weg sie
hat nichts in der demokratie vor
[Applaus]
keine partei die dieser vorsitzenden
durchgehen lässt dass sie das deutsche
volk zu menschen die schon länger hier
leben degradiert und die mit denen die
noch nicht so lange hier leben die
konditionen des zusammenlebens täglich
neu aushandeln soll muss weg und
[Applaus]
und eine kanzlerin die eine schwarz rot
goldene fahne in der ecke entsorgt muss
genauso mit
[Applaus]
liebe freunde jetzt kommt der die csu
ins spiel
ja die mission unserer partei besteht
darin dieses land vor schlimmen und zum
teil unumkehrbaren irrwegen zu bewahren
insofern begrüßen wir es natürlich dass
herr seehofer und herrn söder auf einmal
pläne vorlegen bedienen sie die
sackgasse der berliner asylpolitik
verlassen wollen und die sie ohne große
mühe aus dem afd programm abgeschrieben
und kopiert haben was die csu jetzt
anbietet ist wenn überhaupt die
einleitung einer notbremsung
natürlich sehen wir dahinter aber
vergessen wir niemals die csu ist als
merkel koalitionspartner mit
verantwortlich für alles was diese frau
mit unserem lande angerichtet hat
[Applaus]
die csu ist als merkel koalitionspartner
also auch mitverantwortlich für den
kontrollverlust bei der asylpolitik und
das werden wir ihr im bayerischen wald
kann es immer vorhalten da können sie
sich darauf verlassen
[Applaus]
liebe freunde die migrationsfrage ist
die schicksalsfrage europas dieses thema
lässt sich gar nicht überbewerten
aus einer währungsunion kann man
austreten ein zerstörtes land kann man
wieder aufbauen
eine energiewende umkehren aber einen
bevölkerungsaustausch solchen tempos und
in dieser größenordnung als messstation
kommen einzig die schulen und
kindergärten in frage nur dort sieht man
die zukunft eine sollten doch ein
solcher bevölkerungsaustausch ist
irreversibel und den müssen wir um jeden
preis verhindern dafür sind jahren
getrieben
liebe freunde ich habe diese woche im
bundestag eine europäische lösung der
flüchtlingsfrage vorgeschlagen die
tatsächlich den flüchtlingen helfen
würde
es gibt vier grund tatsachen in der
migrations krise erstens die es zu uns
schaffen sie die stärksten nicht die
schwächsten und bedürftigsten die
derzeitige migration ist ein
darwinistische sweater zweiter die
migration schadet uns deutlich mehr als
sie uns nutzt und drittens die zahl der
menschen die wir neun 2015 aufgenommen
haben wird allein in ägypten pro jahr
nach geboren wir bewirken mit der
aufnahme in afrika absolut nichts
viertens mit einem in afrika
ausgegebenen euro lässt sich zwanzig mal
mehr bewirken als mit einem hier
ausgegeben
[Applaus]
wenn man das zusammen denkt ist die
lösung klar schließen wir die grenze
steigen wir aus den sämtlichen
resettlement programmen der un aus
schicken wir alle heim die sich hier
unberechtigt aufhalten und helfen wir
denen die tatsächlich hilfe braucht ein
auto zelle
[Applaus]
dafür könnte die eu gern einen
europäischen hilfsfonds auflegen für
welchen unsinn werden in der eu
schließlich milliarden ausgegeben
wir haben als parteien nicht das
geringste dagegen menschen in not zu
helfen
aber wir müssen aufhören probleme ohne
ende unser land zu importieren denn es
ist unser land
[Applaus]
liebe freunde es ist für horst seehofer
die letzte chance sich um deutschland
verdient zu machen
er muss sich gegen merkel durchsetzen
oder die koalition platzen lassen und
die zahllosen feiglinge in der cdu die
ihre faust nur in der tasche ballen oder
uns unter vier augen sagen dass wir
recht haben sollten endlich begreifen
dass die zeit nie günstiger warum die
führungen die genossen auf ihren
alterssitz zu schicken
liebe freunde was uns jetzt als
europäische lösung aus brüssel angeboten
wird ist natürlich keine
es gibt keine vereinbarung mit staaten
es gibt keine vereinbarung mit den
nordafrikanischen staaten einige wehren
sich bereits es ist eine totale
luftnummer
es soll alles so weitergehen es soll
dieselbe import von flüchtlingen
weitergehen wie es seit 2005 10
und das wird nur mit sozusagen einen
neuen warteschleife garnieren
das ist keine europäische lösung und
dagegen werden wir sturm laufen und wir
werden die csu im bayerischen wahlkampf
an ihre versprechen erinnern damit
endlich aufzuhören
[Applaus]
ihre freunde donald trump hat als er
erklärte dass die usa nicht den so
genannten global compact von aggression
oder zeichnen zur begründung nur
lakonisch festgestellt wir sind eine
nation kein siedlungsgebiet dasselbe
liebe freunde gilt auch für uns wir
befinden uns in einem kampf gegen kräfte
die ein globales tisches programm der
nationen auflösung und der ethnisch
kulturellen vereinheitlichung verfolgen
unser kampf ist vollkommen defensiv es
geht uns einzig um die erhaltung unserer
art zu leben und zu sein und das für
unsere kinder und kindeskinder
liebe freunde wir halten am begriff des
volkes fest
damit ist kein ethnisch exklusives volk
gemeinden das hat es nie gegeben
aber erfolg hat mit abstammung zu tun
mit traditionen mit kulturellen
gemeinsamkeiten mit heimat heimat ist
ein menschenrecht
umgekehrt hat jeder mensch dem die
heimat genommen wird das recht das
natürliche recht sie zu verteidigen und
wir sind die wahre heimat partei die
unsere deutsche heimat verteidigen und
das werden wir auch im bundestag immer
tun
ich danke ihnen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe freunde das war der angenehme teil
jetzt kommt der unangenehme teil des
formalen und da gibt es viele menschen
die sehr viel besser sind als ich und
ich bitte meinen freund kai gottschalk
dass er jetzt die formalia der eröffnung
des bundes parteitags übernimmt ich
bedanke mich noch einmal bei ihm
[Applaus]